All right.
I want to just do this right at the top of
the show today and get it out of the way.
I don't want it
turned into a big controversy and I just want
to be ideologically and morally consistent
here.
Uh, Bernie Sanders previously said he would
release all of his medical records, his full
medical records, and now he's saying that
he's not going to, and I believe that he should
do it.
I believe it shouldn't be any huge thing that
divides the left.
There is a reason not to vote for Bernie or
anything like that.
Uh, at this point, this is a Biden booted
judge Bernie race.
I believe there is one progressive there.
It's Bernie.
That's who I'm voting for in the primary,
and that's it.
But Bernie Sanders has criticized Donald Trump
for saying he'd release his taxes and never
doing it.
Bernie promised to release his full medical
records before the first votes were cast.
The first votes were cast last Monday in Iowa.
More votes are coming tonight in New Hampshire.
There are a ton of people making this about
things that it's not a way to attack Bernie
or about double standards or whatever.
I don't care about any of that stuff.
I'm voting for Bernie in the primary, but
he promised he would release his full medical
records.
No one made him promise that he chose to do
that, to make that promise.
He said in November that releasing his health
records quote, it's the right thing to do.
The American people have a right to know whether
the person they're going to be voting for
for president is healthy.
He said it a number of times during interviews.
Here is one, of course, when people do have
a right to know about the healthful Senator
and somebody who's born, he propose something
of art's full, full disclosure, and we will
make the appropriate time, all of our medical
records of public for you or for anybody else
who wants to see them.
He was asked on meet the press this weekend
if he would do it and now he says you would
not that he's released enough and that he's
healthy.
Um, the first votes have already been cast.
You did not release your medical records.
You report.
We released a few letters.
Nobody interviewed your doctors.
You did have a, uh, a heart attack.
Apparently shouldn't vote or see your medical
records for super Tuesday documentation.
I think there's any other candidates, but
no other candidates had a heart attack.
Well, look, I am.
Ha, you know, no other candidate is doing
four or five events a day.
Run this country.
No, you have no doubt you proven your metal
here.
But boaters, you heard voters have been concerned
about you can start releasing medical records
that never ends.
We have released a substantial part of all
of our backgrounds.
We have doctors who have cardiologists who
are confirming that I am in good health.
I am in good health.
What changes have you, did the doctors ask
you to make that you've made?
I am trying to walk a little bit more, but
the doesn't allow
me.
They didn't say so I'm not making this anything
more than what it is.
When I tweeted people, I tweeted yesterday
asking, since Bernie promised it, do you think
he should do it?
And I got some messages from people saying,
this is a really cheap way of smearing Bernie
because you don't like them or whatever.
I'm voting for him in the primary.
Okay, I see people saying on Twitter, to me,
Trump never released his taxes, so why does
Bernie have to release his medical records?
Well, he doesn't have to, but saying that
the standard is now, what Donald Trump does
is silly when we're arguing that we're better
than Donald Trump.
Bernie said he would do it and he should.
Plain and simple.
Now there's another angle.
The other angle is, well, other candidates
released letters from their doctors and Bernie
released letters from his doctors and that's
it.
Again, Bernie said he'd release his full medical
records and he hasn't done it.
Do we care?
Do you care?
Are we going to be consistent?
That's really what the issue is here.
Elizabeth Warren released a number of different
things.
She released documents that included a doctor's
note, but it included hematology reports,
chemistry reports, a whole bunch of stuff.
Vice president released a doctor's report
in December and it is less than what Elizabeth
Warren released.
Bernie said he'd release everything and he's
out saying he's not going to do it.
Now, I don't want to be morbid, I don't want
to do anything other than what seems logical
here, but it's widely known that when white
men in their seventies I mean it, you know,
it applies to all races, but not, you know,
I'm just mentioning because we're talking
about Bernie.
When might white men in their seventies have
a heart attack that has an effect on life
expectancy.
There are a lot of studies about life expectancy
after heart attacks and I hope that people
are realizing this isn't Hillary Parkinson
stuff.
There are just real medical facts that I wish
weren't true, but when a, I believe then 77
year old has a heart attack.
The academic research points to this is a,
it's important that full record medical records
be made available period.
So let's not excuse this because it's Bernie
and it's not Trump's taxes or Trump's bogus
medical letter.
Trump should release his taxes.
Trump should actually subject himself to real
rigorous medical examination that he clearly
needs and Bernie should release what he said
he would release.
Period.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
For me, this is very cut and dry and it doesn't
really require any more conversation than
the four minutes I've devoted to it today